you
are not crazy
we need to talk to her
find out why she have to go to the fbi
later what no
hey guys pete here today i'll be
breaking down the penultimate episode of
for all mankind's third season coming
home is more about the problems the crew
at happy valley are facing while trying
to do that coupled with some big
developments that happen on earth it was
a tight episode where everything moved
along like you would expect to set up
the finale it has some really great
highs and then an absolute wtf ending
that i'm still not sure how i feel about
i'm a couple of days late making this
already so i'm gonna have to keep it
shorter than usual if you haven't
watched episode 9 yet there will be
spoilers and with that out of the way
let's get into it we start off with a
five month time jump to a point where
everything has more or less settled down
on mars this threw me off since it
seemed like there was a cliffhanger with
the conversations that the soviets were
having at the end of the last episode
but they appear to just be cool with
kelly's pregnancy now she is very
pregnant in non-optimal conditions and
by the end of the episode they really
need to get her to the phoenix because
she has pre-eclampsia they were able to
salvage the m sam but there's a problem
with making enough fuel in time and
getting everyone on board they also
realize that the rendezvous radar is
broken so they won't be able to dock
with phoenix luckily they find out that
there's a north korean probe nearby that
has one and we'll come back around to
that in a minute at the white house
after ellen refuses to sign a bill that
would give congress direct authority
over nasa's budget and essentially end
space exploration the speaker of the
house brings up that he knows about her
recording device and will subpoena the
tapes looking for evidence of larry's
affair we see them listen to the tapes
and they're much worse than they
remembered if they were to hear them
he'd go to jail for perjury and she'd be
impeached they think about all the
options and they realize there's nothing
they can do so larry offers to call a
press conference to confess he tells her
that she can pretend that she didn't
know make it like he betrayed her too
and that would solve their problem this
is all his fault really and there's some
great setup here because it's nice to
see that he would take responsibility
and even though there's no way around it
that she still doesn't want him to have
to do it because she realizes what kind
of sacrifice this is for him to make of
course at the moment that he gets up to
the podium and gets ready to make the
announcement she steps in to take his
place she tells the american people and
the world that she lied to them and she
comes out and admits she's gay she
delivers a moving speech that it's not
even necessary to summarize because at
this point in the story we understand
where this character is the sacrifices
that she's made what she's risking by
doing this now and why she's telling the
world that she's gay and that she's been
that way since the day she was born
since we've been following this
character for two and a half decades the
scene really delivers jodie balfour
really sells it in her performance and i
really like the moment at the end when
she shares the look with larry because
he's kind of been an annoying character
for most of this season because of this
problem that he caused and it's just
another reminder of everything they've
been through together it was nice to see
margot watching and the speaker of the
house's reaction and then of course
seeing pam if that wasn't enough to hit
you in the heart we watch as everyone at
happy valley learns about her executive
order to allow gay men and women to
openly serve in the military and that
she'll bestow the presidential medal of
freedom on will the actor does an
amazing job of delivering his reaction
to the news and when roland tells him
that he's a brave man and that he's
proud of him it's exactly what you watch
a tv show like this for
elena has bill over to her garage to see
her crazy person bored and then asked
him to tell her she's not crazy after he
sees all the evidence even though he
doesn't want to believe it he knows just
like she does that margot is the one who
gave up the engine design he tries to
get her to go to the fbi but of course
because of what happened with her father
she doesn't want to have anything to do
with them so when he blindsides her by
bringing an agent who he filled in on
everything that's going on to the
outpost she refuses to work with them
and tells him that he's dead to her
they're gonna go ahead and open an
investigation anyway and it really puts
her in a bad spot she has a breakdown in
her garage tearing down all the evidence
from the wall and as she's crying there
her father comes in to comfort her she
kind of tries to put on a strong face
telling him it's nothing and she'll
figure it out and then because of his
dementia he mistakes her for his dead
wife he comes back around and gives her
a hug and it really points out just how
everything is kind of going wrong for
her and these last two sequences are
promising for what's going to come next
because we see some great performances
here from will and from elena and we can
imagine that these will be the
characters that we'll be following in
the next season deb gets his ambitious
plans for mars colonization shot down he
even tried to pull out one of his
inspirational speeches about the
jamestown colony and it had zero effect
on the board who are pretty much tired
of his ideas we learned that they're
gonna push him out and when karen asks
who they're gonna replace him with
richard hilliard says that they want her
as the new ceo it's hard to say how that
will play out i don't know how much
loyalty she has to him i mean i think
they've made it clear that this is
something that she would want to do and
she did have the idea that was going to
save the company because in reality they
are beholden to the shareholders and
mars has been a disaster for everyone
except for north korea and when danielle
and kuznetov get to the probe they find
a living astronaut cosmonaut i'm not
really sure what they call them but he's
alive and he has a gun in his hand this
is the character who was on the surface
and the season two stinger at the end
there this was his boot that we saw and
this has been an idea that people had
but i thought it was more of a joke and
as i said at the beginning i'm just not
really sure what to think about this i'm
sure they figured out how this could be
possible but it still seems a little bit
like a thing that you just throw in
there for a crazy twist more than
anything else at this point i'm guessing
that north korea sent this ship with the
outside hope that they would get there
first and then i guess he could try to
hitch a ride back home since there has
been no talk of this on earth it seems
like he can't get in contact with them
so they just think that he died which
there was probably a really high
percentage chance that that would happen
no matter what and i guess we're gonna
have to wait till next week to see where
it goes from here it's a little bit
strange it feels like there's a lot of
stuff that has to be resolved just for
them to get off the planet so i'm
wondering if they won't do some kind of
a time jump after that happens i mean
right now they don't have enough room
for everyone that's on there and they
just got another passenger there's a lot
of stuff up in the air kelly takes
precedence i guess because she's having
a medical emergency they aren't gonna
have extra fuel to do it more than once
so it's really hard to kind of figure
out how they get all of this stuff
resolved in the last episode because we
still have margot we have to imagine
that she's probably going to go down
there's still the jimmy storyline i
don't know if we're going to see more
from that karen moving in as the ceo
kind of makes sense for her arc but then
what do you do with dev after that and
more than anything else it just seems
like space exploration is over at this
point so there has to be something to
turn that all around because if margot
goes down then you have to imagine that
the nasa bill will pass ellen has no
political power as far as we can tell
they said the reaction was mixed but her
own party will definitely turn on her
because they have to cater to the
religious right even in the 90s it's
hard to see how we get back to the point
where everyone's gung-ho on exploring
space again and i think that is a great
place to leave things for this week
because we got a really big episode
coming next week and we're gonna get all
those answers let me know in the
comments what you think about this
episode and how it's all gonna get
wrapped up please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon